les graffitis illégaux répandent
message super six
hostile à londres ces dernières semaines
ne sont pas l'oeuvre de plusieurs
personnes comme nous le pensions mais
bien d'un seul et même individu
[Musique]
les autorités recommandent de ne pas
approcher l'individu ils sont d'abord
venus chercher les étrangers et je n'ai
rien dit parce que je n'étais pas un
étranger
puis sont venus chercher les
manifestants et je n'ai rien dit
parce que je m'étais par un manifestant
[Musique]
puis ils sont venus chercher les
journalistes et je n'ai rien dit
parce que je n'étais pas un journaliste
et plus sont venus chercher les artistes
de rue mais je n'ai rien
parce que je ne suis pas un artiste de
rue
[Applaudissements]
puis j'ai fini par comprendre qu'il
viendrait me chercher et qu'il n'y
aurait plus personne pourtant leur
mouvement
[Musique]
à nos yeux des chefs
désolé mais bon sang ok on est dans la
merde foot on shore d'ici
et je pense juste qu'on n'en parle pas
assez oui bien sûr et rien de plus
injuste ne pas les filles ne pas pouvoir
faire ce qui passionne la nuit a été
longue et londres et plongée dans le
chaos
les principales routes de la ville sont
bloquées des centaines de puits
mais chaque tiens tiens tiens bienvenue
dans la résistance
voici un cadeau pour nos nouveaux
membres à la puce vous auriez pu me dire
que c'était une fête costumée
essayez le le principal suspect a été
identifié il s'agirait de david ford
un chauffeur de taxi âgé de 43 ans
inconnu des forces de l'ordre il est
actuellement considéré comme un
terroriste il est interdit de
l'approcher les autorités conseillent à
tous les résidents
[Musique]